[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Am 10. Mai ist Muttertag
und auch der Geburtstag meiner Mama.
Deswegen möchte ich heute kleine Törtchen machen.
Und Muttertag, weil es ja im Mai ist,
ist für mich immer was mit Erdbeere.
Ich verbinde immer Erdbeeren mit Muttertag.
Also gibt es heute kleine Erdbeertörtchen.
Die werden dann später mit Mirror Glaze überzogen.
Und ihr könnt sie wirklich super vorbereiten,
da man die Törtchen vorher gut einfrieren kann.
Also könnt ihr sie auch gerne
schon ein, zwei Tage vorher bereit machen
und dann einfach am Muttertag dann fertig dekorieren.
Fertig!
Und dann habt ihr so kleine Törtchen.
Die könnt ihr dann an die Mama
und an die Schwiegermama verschenken.
Also richtig ein richtig tolles Rezept zum Teilen.
Und ich mache jetzt zuerst einmal einen Kuchenteig
und zwar einen Red Velvet Kuchenteig.
Red Velvet heißt einfach roter Samt,
weil damals dieser Kuchen gemacht wurde mit Kakao
und es wurde einfach ein bisschen Säure dazu gegeben,
Essig oder eben Buttermilch,
und dadurch hat sich der Kakao verfärbt in Rot.
Und deswegen hieß dann eben der Kuchen so.
Ich helfe heute aber auch noch
ein bisschen mit roter Farbpaste nach.
So haben wir wirklich ein schönes, sattes Rot.
Also für den Teig – das ist ein Rührteig –
verwende ich 100 Gramm weiche Butter,
100 Gramm Zucker, eine Prise Salz und etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Hier habe ich noch etwas rote Farbpaste.
Zwei Eier, die sind schon zimmerwarm.
150 Gramm Mehl,
jeweils einen Teelöffel Kakao und Backpulver,
einen Esslöffel Essig
– da nehme ich jetzt einen Fruchtessig –
und 75 Gramm warme Milch.
Jetzt nehme ich zuerst die weiche Butter
und verrühre sie dann mit dem Salz und Zucker
richtig schön cremig.
Das dauert so etwa vier bis fünf Minuten.
[Musik]
Das wird jetzt ein Muttertagsrezept.
>> SAMIRA: Wann ist Muttertag?
>> SALLY: Am 10. Mai, wenn Oma Geburtstag hat.
Oma hat Geburtstag und Muttertag.
Wenn die Butter-Zucker-Masse dann soweit ist,
dann die Eier einzeln dazu geben,
also immer eins nach dem anderen.
So. Jetzt habe ich eine fleißige Küchenhilfe hier.
Jetzt kannst du wieder stärker machen.
Für mich ist jeder Tag Muttertag,
weil ihr mir immer viel helft und immer für mich backt
und Bilder malt,
ihr Mäuse.
>> SAMIRA: Mein Arm fällt gleich ab.
>> SALLY: Soll ich dir helfen?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Magst du reinschütten?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Komm, dann rühre ich wieder weiter.
Und los!
Und dann gleich die Schüssel ins Waschbecken.
Dann wasche ich die gleich weg.
>> SAMIRA: Und mit Essig.
>> SALLY: Und jetzt kommt schon mal die Farbe dazu.
Und da nehmen wir Farbpaste,
weil die einfach superintensiv ist.
>> SAMIRA: Darf ich die reinmachen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Perfekt. Das reicht schon.
So.
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Jetzt.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Hier kann ich jetzt schon mal Backpulver...
Ich dachte gerade, es schneit.
Aber das ist der Baum.
>> JOSH: Das sind die Blüten.
>> SALLY: Das sind die Blüten am Baum.
Ich dachte gerade: "O Gott, es..."
>> SAMIRA: Was ist mait?
>> SALLY: Es schneit.
>> SAMIRA: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Nee. Die weißen Blüten fallen gerade vom Baum
und das sieht echt aus wie Schnee.
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe "mait" verstanden.
>> SALLY: Jetzt kann ich hier schon mal
Mehl, Backpulver und Kakao vermischen.
>> SAMIRA: Darf ich das machen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich glaube, wir sieben es auch kurz,
damit es keine Klümpchen gibt.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt hier reinsieben.
Vorsicht auf deine Ärmelchen hier.
Und ich gebe schon mal Essig dazu
und die Milch.
Okay.
Die Milch, die darf auch gerne warm sein.
Und jetzt ganz kurz verrühren.
Und ihr könnt den Essig auch weglassen,
wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel Buttermilch nehmt.
Da ist dann schon Säure drin.
Oder auch einen Spritzer Zitronensaft.
>> SAMIRA: Ja, das Braune sieht man auch gar nicht.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist ja voll cool.
>> SALLY: Cool, nicht?
Und jetzt nur noch ganz kurz rühren.
Willst du?
>> SAMIRA: Beide.
>> SALLY: Beide?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Jetzt fülle ich den Teig in meine Backform.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach
mein Backblech mit dem Backrahmen dran
und habe den auf 25 mal 25 cm eingestellt.
Ich will nämlich jetzt nur eine ganz dünne Teigplatte.
Jetzt hier kurz verteilen.
Und dann kann die Teigplatte schon in den Backofen.
Und in der Zwischenzeit
kann ich mich schon mal um die Creme kümmern.
Ich glaube, damit die Teigplatte richtig dünn wird,
ziehe ich es doch auseinander und mache
30 mal 30 cm.
>> SAMIRA: Ich hatte schon mal einen sehr keksigen
Kuchen gemacht.
Der war so dünn!
>> SALLY: Weil?
>> SAMIRA: Weil
ich Backpulver vergessen habe.
>> SALLY: Und es war witzig,
denn ich hatte den gleichen Zitronenkuchen
auch damals im gleichen Alter gemacht
und hatte auch einmal Backpulver vergessen.
Da hatten wir auch Zitronenkekse
statt Zitronenkuchen.
Aber nicht schlimm.
Es war trotzdem voll lecker.
>> SAMIRA: Und er war vegan!
Nein. Da waren Eier drin.
>> SALLY: Da waren Eier drin. Ja.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist jetzt gebacken.
Und ich habe ihn auch schon abkühlen lassen.
Also so sieht er aus, wenn er fertig ist.
Den stelle ich jetzt kurz zur Seite
und kann mich jetzt schon mal
um die Erdbeermousse kümmern.
Für die Erdbeermousse könnt ihr jetzt
entweder frische Erdbeeren benutzen oder auch gefrorene.
Ich nehme da auch immer ganz gerne gefrorene Erdbeeren.
Denn die werden ganz reif geerntet
und dann sofort eingefroren
und haben wirklich den vollen Geschmack.
Dafür brauche ich also
250 Gramm Erdbeeren, frische oder tiefgefrorene,
einen Teelöffel Zitronensaft,
120 Gramm Magerquark,
30 Gramm Puderzucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
11 Gramm gemahlene Gelatine,
70 Gramm Sahne
und 200 Gramm Sahne.
Jetzt könnt ihr zuerst die kleine Menge Sahne nehmen
und mit der Gelatine verrühren
und die dann kurz quellen lassen.
Und hier nehme ich jetzt Gelatine,
weil nämlich das Ganze wie so eine Mousse wird.
Also es soll eine Moussetextur haben.
Ihr könnt auch Agar Agar benutzen,
also pflanzliches Geliermittel.
Dann habt ihr einfach keine Gelatine mit dabei.
Aber Agar Agar ist ein bisschen fester.
Also es bindet viel fester.
Wenn euch das nicht stört, nehmt ihr einfach Agar Agar.
Beachtet da aber,
dass ich dann nicht noch mal Sahne braucht,
um das Agar Agar etwas quellen zu lassen,
sondern ihr könnt dann das Agar Agar
direkt mit der gleichen Menge Wasser, also hier 70 Gramm,
einfach zu den Erdbeeren dazu geben,
damit pürieren und dann aufkochen lassen.
Also da ist einfach die Zubereitung ein bisschen anders.
Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nur eine Geschmackssache,
also so eine Textursache.
Und ich will eben, dass es schön weich und mousseartig wird.
Daher nehme ich jetzt Gelatine.
Das muss jetzt hier ein bisschen quellen,
so etwa zehn Minuten.
In der Zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
hier schon mal die Erdbeeren pürieren.
Das sieht aus wie ein trauriger Smiley.
So.
Ein fröhlicher Smiley.
So, jetzt hier einfach ein bisschen Zitronensaft reingeben
und pürieren.
Danke, Schatz.
>> SAMIRA: Bitte.
Machst du das gerade für die Muttertagstorte?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ich habe die Erdbeeren übrigens auftauen lassen.
[Musik]
Gut.
Samira, du darfst das schon mal in den Topf einfüllen.
Super!
Genau, schön auskratzen.
Und das erwärme ich jetzt gleich.
Aufkochen muss ich es jetzt im Prinzip nicht.
Aber ich lasse es jetzt trotzdem ganz kurz aufkochen.
So etwa eine halbe Minute bis Minute köcheln lassen.
Du kannst das schon mal rühren.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
hier schon mal den Quark verrühren.
Also den Quark hier verrühren mit etwas Puderzucker
und Vanilleextrakt.
Vanille passt nämlich perfekt zu Erdbeeren.
>> SAMIRA: Das riecht so gut!
>> SALLY: Hm.
[Musik]
Und wenn ihr dann den Quark verrührt habt,
könnt ihr auch noch die Sahne steifschlagen.
[Musik]
Die Sahne ist jetzt steif.
Die stelle ich ganz kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Denn ich muss jetzt ganz kurz noch auf die Gelatine warten.
Die ist noch nicht ganz soweit.
Und dann geht es gleich weiter.
Auf jeden Fall die Erdbeermasse warmhalten,
nicht abkühlen lassen.
Denn die Gelatine wird da gleich drin aufgelöst.
Guck mal, jetzt kannst du hier schon mal den Teig lösen
und zwar erst das Backpapier drunter wegziehen.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Guck, hier.
Und dann so wegrollen.
Und den Teigrahmen lösen.
Genau.
Und ich kann jetzt hier schon mal...
Die Gelatine, die ist jetzt schön gequollen,
wie man sieht, ganz fest geworden.
Und die kommt jetzt hier in die Erdbeermasse rein.
Die ist ja noch warm.
Und da wirklich darauf achten,
dass Gelatine niemals gekocht werden darf,
ganz anders als Agar Agar oder Agartine.
Sonst verliert sie nämlich ihre Bindeeigenschaft.
Also nur in warmen Dingen auflösen.
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Boah, ist der dünn!
>> SALLY: Hm.
So brauchen wir den auch, ganz dünn.
Jetzt habe ich also hier diese vier Bestandteile.
Einmal den Kuchen,
die Sahne,
den Quark
und die Erdbeermasse.
Und jetzt bereitet ihr am besten schon eure Form vor.
Ich backe nicht gerne in Silikonförmchen,
aber ich nehme sie ganz gerne,
um Kuchen und Cremes in Form zu bringen.
Und gerade bei Mirror Glaze ist es wirklich superwichtig,
dass ihr außen eine perfekt gerade Fläche
und eine glatte Fläche habt.
Und da eignen sich Silikonförmchen echt gut.
Wir nehmen jetzt hier diese kleinen Herzchen.
Denn die dekorieren wir später als
Erdbeeren.
Voll süß!
Okay.
Und die haben jetzt auch nicht so ein großes Volumen.
Also so ein kleines Törtchen
ist dann echt perfekt zum Verschenken.
>> SAMIRA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Jetzt gebe ich...
Moment. Jetzt muss ich nämlich schnell arbeiten, Samira,
wegen der Gelatine.
Jetzt gebe ich hier ein paar Esslöffel
der Quarkmasse hinein,
um einfach die Gelatine an die Temperatur anzupassen.
Und jetzt hier zurück
in den großen Topf.
>> SAMIRA: Ist das eine Mirror Glaze?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Also später, wenn es gefroren ist.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Das sieht gerade noch nicht so wie eine Mirror Glaze aus.
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist ja nicht die Mirror Glaze.
Das wird jetzt die Erdbeermousse.
Und die Mirror Glaze kommt später drauf.
Jetzt die Sahne kurz unterheben.
Und hier mache ich auch immer gerne eine Mousse
bei den Mirror Glaze Törtchen,
weil ich die jetzt schön eingießen kann
und dadurch wird sie eben auch schön glatt später.
Dann in die Förmchen gießen.
Und nicht ganz voll, denn
gleich kommt ja noch der Tortendeckel drauf,
der Boden.
>> SAMIRA: Bleibt da noch was übrig?
>> SALLY: Bestimmt.
>> SAMIRA: Dann kann ich auch einen Kuchen machen.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich fülle es kurz hier rein.
Dann kann ich es besser einfüllen, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Ja, denke ich auch.
Weil die ist auch so schwer.
>> SALLY: Hm.
[Musik]
Ein bisschen was haben wir noch übrig.
Am besten setzt ihr euch das
Förmchen vorher schon
auf eine Unterlage.
Ich denke da nur jedes Mal nicht dran.
Kurz klopfen.
Perfekt!
Sieht schon richtig gut aus, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, ein, zwei Tröpfchen
kann ich hier noch reingeben.
Und dann...
>> SAMIRA: ... ist der Rest für mich.
>> SALLY: Der Rest ist gleich für dich.
Wir füllen den Rest noch in andere Förmchen ein.
Dann haben wir noch mehr Törtchen, gell?
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einen Ausstecher,
der zu eurer Form passt.
Denn ich möchte jetzt
den Kuchen hier als Boden sozusagen haben.
Ich denke,
das könnte passen.
Wir probieren es.
>> SAMIRA: Ich möchte nämlich
auch einen kleinen Kuchen machen.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen größer dürfte es sein.
Aber das macht gar nichts.
Denn ihr müsst jetzt darauf achten,
dass die Form glatt abschließt.
Also den Kuchen einfach leicht eindrücken.
Gerne noch mal mit ein paar Tröpfchen auffüllen.
[Musik]
So ist es perfekt.
Schön gerade.
>> SAMIRA: Soll ich das hier auch ausstanzen?
>> SALLY: Du stanzt aus, ich setze rein, hä?
Einfach so, dass es hier schön glatt abschließt, okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
Das ist wie im Kindergarten.
Da haben wir das auch immer mit Knete gemacht,
zuerst so einen Kuchenboden gemacht aus Knete,
aus der magischen Knete.
Und dann
haben wir sie ausgestanzt.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Das kommt jetzt so in den Gefrierschrank,
damit die Törtchen einfrieren können.
Denn, wenn wir da eine Mirror Glaze darüber ziehen,
muss der Untergrund schön gefroren sein,
damit die Mirror Glaze schön drauf haften bleibt
und eben auch wunderschön glatt wird.
Aus dem Rest mache ich jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach noch
die anderen kleinen Förmchen.
Aber ihr könnt auch aus dem Rest
einfach kleine Löffeldesserts machen.
[Musik]
Die Törtchen sind jetzt eingefroren.
Ich habe sie einfach über Nacht ins Gefrierfach gestellt.
Aber es reichen da wirklich auch vier bis fünf Stunden,
bis sie komplett gefroren sind.
Jetzt kommt die Mirror Glaze Schicht darüber.
Entweder macht ihr jetzt mein Grundrezept
und macht die Mirror Glaze einfach komplett selbst.
Da braucht man ein paar Zutaten dafür,
aber man kann es wirklich super zubereiten.
Oder ihr verwendet, so wie ich jetzt,
weil es einfach schneller geht und einfacher geht,
die Mirror Glaze hier.
Und hier brauche ich jetzt einfach nur
ein Päckchen Mirror Glaze – da nehme ich jetzt rosa,
die ist von Küchle –
und 400 Gramm Milch.
Und ich nehme dann noch etwas rote Farbpaste.
Denn ich möchte eine rote Mirror Glaze,
damit die Törtchen eben auch wie eine Erdbeere aussehen.
Ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal
hier die Milch in einen Topf geben
und ganz kurz aufkochen lassen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt könnt ihr hier...
Also die Milch habe ich jetzt wieder runtergezogen.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier
die Mirror Glaze klümpchenfrei einrühren.
[Musik]
Das Rosa wäre jetzt schon perfekt,
um die Herzchen zu überziehen.
Aber dadurch, dass es Erdbeeren werden sollen,
gebe ich noch ein bisschen rote Farbpaste dazu,
damit es einfach ein schönes, sattes Rot wird.
Und jetzt ist auch gleich ganz wichtig,
dass die Mirror Glaze abkühlt auf etwa 35°C,
also etwa Handwärme.
Und damit kann ich dann die gefrorenen Törtchen überziehen.
Also, während die jetzt hier abkühlt,
– ich rühre sie dann noch immer wieder durch –
kann ich schon mal die Törtchen
aus den Silikonformen rausnehmen,
also rausstürzen, auf ein Gitter schon mal stellen,
solange aber noch mal einfrieren
und gleich dann eben überziehen mit der Mirror Glaze.
[Musik]
Hier löse ich jetzt die Törtchen
einfach am Silikonrand zuerst.
Dann
kann ich sie schön glatt rausstürzen.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr die Mirror Glaze komplett selbst machen möchtet,
dann gebt ihr Glukosesirup
mit Zucker und Wasser in einen Topf
und lasst es so lange kochen, bis ihr 105°C erreicht habt.
Also da muss man auf jeden Fall mit Thermometer arbeiten.
Anschließend kommt Kondensmilch dazu.
Und zwar die gesüßte Kondensmilch, also die etwas dickere.
Da braucht man dann schon so ein paar spezielle Zutaten.
Gerade der Glukosesirup ist da eben superwichtig.
Dann etwas gequollene Gelatine.
Also gemahlene Gelatine vorher einweichen lassen.
Die braucht man natürlich zum Binden.
Und da auch immer darauf achten,
dass Gelatine nicht kochen darf.
Auch diese Mirror Glaze,
die könnt ihr natürlich auch aufbewahren,
wenn ihr was übrig habt,
und später noch mal in der Mikrowelle zum Beispiel erwärmen,
aber eben nicht kochen lassen.
Und weiße Schokolade.
Und dann fehlt hier nur noch die Farbe.
Die könnt ihr dann
eben auch als Lebensmittelfarbpaste dazu geben.
Und dann habt ihr die selbst hergestellte Mirror Glaze.
Wie gesagt, das ist ein bisschen aufwendiger,
vor allem mit den speziellen Zutaten, die man braucht.
Und auf jeden Fall sollte man mit dem Thermometer arbeiten.
[Musik]
Damit die Mirror Glaze jetzt keine Luftbläschen hat,
könnt ihr sie jetzt gerne noch sieben,
also durch ein ganz feines Haarsieb gießen.
Am besten mit einem Trichter dann auch direkt in ein Gefäß.
Ihr dürft jetzt auch nicht zu lange warten.
Also sie darf jetzt auch nicht zu kalt werden.
Falls sie doch mal zu kalt geworden ist,
könnt ihr sie im Wasserbad, wie gesagt, noch mal erwärmen.
Und ich lasse die jetzt hier ganz langsam durchfließen.
Und so entferne ich jetzt alle Luftblasen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt einfach über die gefrorenen Törtchen drübergießen.
Eine Auffangschale darunterlegen.
Denn ihr könnt ja die Mirror Glaze einfach noch mal erwärmen
und weiter benutzen.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt euch mal vier Herzchen
mit der selbst gemachten Mirror Glaze überzogen
und vier mit der Küchle Mirror Glaze.
Und, was richtig gut auffällt,
also die, die ich gemacht habe,
die ist ein bisschen dünn,
also die deckt nicht ganz so gut.
Ich glaube, ich hätte sie einfach noch
ein bisschen stehen lassen müssen wahrscheinlich
und vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Farbe reingeben müssen.
Und die hier, die habe ich jetzt hier
mit der Küchle Mirror Glaze gemacht,
die ist wirklich schön deckend.
Dass es jetzt noch wie schöne Erdbeeren aussieht,
nehme ich ein bisschen Sesam für die Oberfläche
und mache jetzt hier wie so kleine Erdbeerkörnchen rein.
Also der Perfektionist
würde sie jetzt mit der Pinzette darauf setzen,
damit alle in eine Richtung gucken.
Nein, das mache ich heute nicht.
[Musik]
Die Törtchen sind jetzt fast fertig.
Aber natürlich fehlt noch das Grün der Erdbeere.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt hier etwas grünen Fondant.
Den verknete ich gerade mit etwas CMC, also Cellulosepulver.
Ihr könnt auch einfach Blütenpaste mit einkneten,
damit der Fondant einfach ein bisschen aushärten kann.
Ihr könnt auch Marzipan nehmen stattdessen,
wenn ihr das leckerer findet.
Also einfach so ein bisschen was zum Modellieren.
Jetzt kann ich hier den Fondant dünn ausrollen
und daraus jetzt kleine Blätter ausstechen.
Ich habe jetzt keine Erdbeerblätterausstecher,
aber ich nehme einfach so was Ähnliches.
Ich habe jetzt hier einmal so ein sternförmiges Blatt
und so ein strukturiertes Blatt.
Das kann ich jetzt hier ausstechen.
Und, wenn ihr möchtet,
könnt ihr dann noch etwas Pulverfarbe nehmen
einfach zum Schattieren.
Das muss aber nicht sein.
Und ich steche die immer aus
und stanze dann rein.
Dann habt ihr nämlich schön
diese Struktur mit dabei.
[Musik]
Mit Pulverfarben kriegt man da halt
einfach noch mal so ein bisschen
das Ganze realistischer hin.
Also es sieht dann schon
immer noch einen Ticken besser aus.
Und? Gefällt es dir?
>> SAMIRA: Ja!
Die sehen voll schön aus!
Und auch so glatt.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und da kommen jetzt noch die grünen Teile dran und dann...
>> SAMIRA: Sollen das Erdbeeren sein?
>> SALLY: Ja!
Hast du es erkannt gleich?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Coole Idee, oder?
>> SAMIRA: Warte.
Hier steht es noch ein
>> SALLY: Noch nicht!
>> SAMIRA: bisschen.
>> SALLY: Ja, genau. Die kannst du noch flach drücken.
>> SAMIRA: Und hier auch.
So.
>> SALLY: Ich zeige euch jetzt mal
anhand eines Törtchens, wie es jetzt fertiggestellt wird.
Ich nehme jetzt hier passend zum Mirror Glaze Törtchen
das Mirror Glaze Geschirr
und suche jetzt eine Erdbeere aus.
>> SAMIRA: Hier ist die.
Das könntest du ja als Apfel machen.
>> SALLY: Hm. Stimmt.
>> SAMIRA: Die hängen da wie so Fäden runter.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Man muss die auch immer gut abtropfen lassen.
Jetzt sieht man ja auch schon, dass die Glasur fest wird.
Und jetzt kann man es praktisch
so runternehmen.
>> SAMIRA: Burası biraz şilt.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube,
ich nehme jetzt sogar zwei übereinander,
damit ich die Vorder- und die Rückseite habe.
Hm. Die klebe ich dann dort dran mit essbarem Kleber.
[Musik]
Süß!
Ich glaube, die Blätter sind sogar zu viel.
Mh. Ich glaube, ich lasse es so.
Kleines Erdbeertörtchen.
Och, süß!
[Musik]
Die Törtchen sind jetzt aufgetaut und verzehrbereit!
Und heute darf Sarah probieren.
>> SARAH: Yay!
Hallo!
>> SALLY: Ich finde, Sarah, wenn du kommst, also ins Video,
dann solltest du immer was singen.
Muttertag.
>> SARAH: Aber ich kenne keinen Muttertagssong.
>> SALLY: Mama!
>> SARAH: U-uh-uh!
Didn't mean to make you cry.
>> SALLY: Ja, okay. Ist ein bisschen traurig.
Ich kriege schon eine Gänsehaut!
>> SARAH: Ich kenne sonst keinen.
Gibt es einen Muttertagssong?
Nee.
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> SARAH: Da bastelt man nur. Man singt nicht.
>> SALLY: Ja. Man bastelt und backt.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Und, da ich beides nicht kann,
habe ich trotzdem immer gesungen.
>> SALLY: Aber das kannst du nachmachen,
Mirror Glaze Törtchen.
>> SARAH: Echt? Ist das einfach?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Kriege ich das hin?
>> SALLY: Ja, das kriegst du hin.
>> SARAH: Ich probiere das mal.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Das sind Erdbeertörtchen.
>> SARAH: Like me.
>> SALLY: Ja!
Du bist auch so ein Erdbeertörtchen.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Ich finde so dieses...
>> SARAH: Die Konsistenz ist interessant.
>> SALLY: Ja. So dieses Angabeln ist immer so cool.
Ist halt ein Erdbeertörtchen.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Man schmeckt aber die Erdbeere gut raus, gell?
Hinten raus.
>> SARAH: Voll!
Das schmeckt voll interessant.
>> SALLY: Das ist so eine Quark-Erdbeer-Creme.
>> SARAH: Hm.
Das erinnert mich an irgendwas.
>> SALLY: Erdbeerjoghurt?
>> SARAH: Ja.
Tatsächlich. Oder
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> SARAH: Erdbeereis.
>> SALLY: Stimmt!
Erdbeereis!
Das ist wie ein Erdbeereis. >> SARAH: Zufällig.
>> SALLY: Statt dem roten Boden,
ich glaube, optisch würde es mir besser gefallen,
wenn der Boden Schoko wäre.
So ein Schokoboden.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht rot, sondern dunkel.
>> SARAH: Stimmt. Ja.
Das wäre auch schön.
>> SALLY: Jetzt, wo ich es so angable, anlöffle,
denke ich so, ja, hätte vielleicht besser gepasst.
Aber ist ja nicht schlimm.
Ihr könnt ja so, wie ihr möchtet.
>> SARAH: Wir haben ja Photoshop.
>> SALLY: Schoko.
Ja, genau.
Macht ihr dann per Photoshop den Boden einfach?
>> SARAH: Ja!
Wir können ihn dunkel machen.
>> SALLY: Ja. Also den könnt ihr dunkler machen.
Dann habt ihr noch so eine Schoko-
mehr eine Schokonote noch mit drin.
Aber so ist er eigentlich ganz cool, gell?
>> SARAH: Schmeckt sehr lecker.
>> SALLY: Ich finde es auch.
Vor allem schmeckt es leicht.
Und es ist wirklich einfach in der Herstellung,
wenn man eben die Silikonform benutzt.
Und dann muss man es einfrieren lassen
und einfach Mirror Glaze drübergießen.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Das war es.
Fertig.
So viel.
Und ich finde die Sesamkörner
echt süß!
Ja.
>> SARAH: Und die Form ist natürlich,
da freut sich jede Mutter.
>> SALLY: Ja, die Mama.
Und vor allem kann man teilen.
Man hat nicht nur eine Torte,
sondern kann teilen
und kann noch der Schwiegermama eine geben.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und vielleicht auch der Oma und der Tante.
Ja.
>> SARAH: Ist eine gute Idee.
Irgendwie so allen Müttern, die man mag und die man kennt.
Ja.
Also probiert das Rezept gerne mal aus.
Falls diese kleinen Törtchen
es auf eure Muttertags-To-do-Backliste schaffen,
dann postet gerne ein Foto und markiert mich darauf.
Dann kann ich es mir nämlich auch anschauen.
Und ich wünsche jetzt allen Mamas
jetzt schon einmal einen wunderschönen Muttertag!
Tschüss!
>> SARAH: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Murat hat auch mal eine Muttertagstorte gemacht.
>> SARAH: Was war das?
>> SALLY: Mit Himbeeren.
Die war auch richtig cool.
>> SARAH: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Hat sich seine Mutter gefreut?
>> SALLY: Meine Mama. Ja.
>> SARAH: Ah, für seine...
>> SALLY: Seine wohnt ja leider nicht da.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Voll gut!
>> SARAH: Sind echt lecker.
>> SALLY: So.
>> SARAH: Gut.
>> SALLY: Die nehmen wir mal noch mit.
Kaffee und fertig.
[Musik]